Some people call light and vitality, but for some reason
Even if you seem to have just been able to sleep,
You will still suffer from drowsiness and impotence throughout the day
So, why are you always tired?
If you know that the number of hours of sleep is not a problem
The second most common cause of stress
It comes from lack of activity and poor nutrition
A study followed by a study proved that adults
Who practiced light exercises several times a week, became active six weeks later
People who have been trained regularly have also been encouraged to sleep better
Although studies show they do not sleep longer
But if this does not benefit you, do not rush to the cup of your strength
While many studies have shown that coffee is beneficial to your health
Research has shown that relying on it makes you need to sleep more
Coffee reverses the action of adenosine in the brain
Which accumulates throughout the day
It makes you feel sleepy at night
But the consumption of coffee or energy drinks before bedtime by 6 hours
Will affect the quality of sleep
So we see people who do not use coffee
They are often less tired in the morning
Make sure you drink enough water
One study found that the water shortage in the body by 1.5%
It can cause difficulty concentrating
Your blood gets more intense, causing slow oxygen and nutrients
For muscles and organs
However a 2% shortfall is enough to make you thirsty
So there is no need to drink gallons of water
Staying wet throughout the day will certainly help
Urine should be yellow
Any clogging of color suggests your need for water
A cup of wine or alcohol before bedtime
They can affect your day
Studies have found that you are in the case of buzz
You will sleep faster
But the quality of your sleep is much worse
Especially during the second half of sleep
In the end alcohol reduces the sleep you get
And if you drink and sleep on the weekend
Be aware that a fixed sleep schedule is the solution
Try to wake up at your usual times on weekdays
And get naps for 20 minutes during the day
This will make you recharge your body without having to sleep long
Or made you more tired
Sleep in time on Sunday evening
Makes Monday morning easier
And certainly your psychological state also has a role
Anxiety is a big thing
Fear of people's words or feeling nervous about work
Or be concerned about every decision you make
It will make you tired and tired
Fatigue is one of the main causes of anxiety disorders
Not only that, anxiety can affect the quality of sleep
Another serious risk, depression can be a cause of physical and emotional pain
An increase in sleep will not necessarily be a solution
Some anxiety causes insomnia
Or inability to sleep
Unfortunately, there is no quick cure for 10% of Americans
Who suffer from depression
So if you think you are suffering from acetab
Go to a doctor or psychologist
In the end you might be a night person like a mole
About 10% of the population has genes
Keep them awake late at night
But living in a day-to-day world makes it difficult
You get enough sleep
In fact scientists call it the phenomenon of different timing community
The night person feels that he is living within the wrong timing every day
If you do not feel any improvement, you may have a medical problem
Cause you fatigue so you should talk to a specialist about them
Got a question you want to answer?
Ask in comments or on Facebook and Twitter
Follow us to more science videos